he
bought a knife walked into the salon
where holly was working as a hairdresser
and stabbed her 14 times
holly gazard was just 20 years old when
her ex-boyfriend murdered her that was
in 2014. since then many more women have
been murdered and her father says not
enough progress has been made
when i read the sentencing of sarah
everard and i read the
victim impact statements from her mum
and dad and her sister it took me right
back to when we had those victim impact
statements in the court we've not come a
long way in that sense you know i'm
still hearing the same things as we said
when holly was killed
if women were already frightened to walk
the streets at night the recent deaths
of sarah everard and sabine nessa have
reinforced those fears and sparked a
conversation about how to protect women
and telecoms company bt have come up
with one possible solution
the walk me home service which is
currently in development would allow
users to opt in to a gps tracking
service it will be activated by calling
888 before embarking on a journey if the
user doesn't reach their destination on
time it will trigger an alert and
emergency contacts and the police will
be called
latest figures show that in the last
decade
1425 women were killed by a man that's
around one every three days but when
sarah everard was walking through a
clapham common she was on the phone to
her boyfriend and sabine anessa was
killed just meters away from her home
suggesting tracking women may not be the
solution
and the women of clapham common had
mixed reactions
i think it's good to have the option
there to use it um but again completely
agree
there's a massive educational piece that
needs to be done if it reassures you as
a person a man or woman then i think
it's a great thing i don't actually like
the idea of having my data trapped and
people having like tabs on me all the
time i'll probably stick to sharing my
whatsapp location with family and
friends
this app has been backed by the home
secretary and is aiming to launch ahead
of christmas but there are already apps
out there including one set up by nick
which has hundreds of thousands of users
and he says these methods may only work
in the short term
this is a bigger
bigger fish than just providing an app
or a phone line to help keep people safe
it's a society issue
but change in the culture of society
doesn't occur overnight this app may not
address all the dangers facing women and
girls but could be one way that some
women feel safer on the streets
shimane freeman powell sky news